c'est l'heure d'aller la chercher qu'est
ce qu'il fait déjà jour là prenez tous
et de lens wii music ça pique
tout le monde a changé de kenzo oui il a
eu bien léger tient en oublie
je suis plus à bruit
[Musique]
excellent
c'en est fini de l'âge de pierre le holà
te prends
[Musique]
mythe ou tu sors de l'âge de pierre je
ferai tout pour sauver ma tribu
l'art mg par là
[Applaudissements]
un homme des cavernes des câbles vous
allez laisser ma tribu tranquille pour
qui te prends-tu qu'on l'emmène et qu'on
le tire lentement et crêtes
si on gagne ils nous laisseront vivre en
paix dans notre vallée
oui mais si jamais on perd oui alors là
ils nous feront travaillaient au fond
d'une mine jusqu'à la fin de notre vie
c'est quoi une mine
je trouve très courageux
[Musique]
wahou
mais pour nier quoi
[Musique]
autre 60
tu restes là on doit surtout pas ce qu'a
remarqué d'accord
e
[Musique]